a city divided this is where ethnic Susu
and medical live side-by-side in peace
and this is where the Fulani live move
shouts this paratrooper they're armed
with live rounds of ammunition since the
beginning of the protest against
president alpha comte's attempt extend
his stay in power the Capitals Fulani
districts look and feel like a war zone
security forces are shooting down
protesters this is mobile phone footage
of mr. and mrs. balling unconscious one
was shot in the leg the other had a
large rock thrown to her head they were
mourning the loss of two of their
nephews who were shot dead by armed
soldiers when they came back after them
they survived the attack still in grief
and seething with anger the soldiers
told me they are paid to kill the
polanyi's and that they will kill us
one by one the one responsible for this
is alpha conde soldiers are being paid
by the President to assassinate us while
full on ease make up the ethnic majority
in Guinea never has a felony come to
power hundreds of them are being rounded
up and arrested because they are
protesting against the 81 year old
president's attempt to change the
Constitution and to run for a third
mandate opposition leaders tell you Java
accuses the president of fuelling ethnic
divisions we have to fight tribalism and
ethnic politics because it's dividing us
and it could create so much hatred and
violence that it could cause a civil war
we asked the information Minister why
the government are targeting felonies
but he would not allow us to broadcast
the interview this is a touchy subject
he explained after several days of
protests calm has returned in most
neighborhoods but not in Fulani areas
this is what remains of a military
outpost it was burned to the ground by
protesters because it's inside a Fulani
neighborhood now the military has
replaced that with this big white tent
and they're just behind you keeping a
close watch on this situation because
earlier
on demonstrators threw stones at them
they responded by firing shots it's
still very much a tense situation here
despite calls for dialogue by president
Alfa comme de Medici Sousou in Fulani
each ethnic group has its political
leader with its own grievances something
that president Alfa Conde will have to
address if he wants to extend his stay
in power and unite a population divided
by politics nicholas hawk al jazeera
Conakry